hello in this video i explain
how you deal with categorical independent
variables in your government
model categorical variables are
either original or nominal
variables and we start with
that as independent variables
or projectors
either metric or categorical
variables with two characteristics
can be used what we do  must
if we have more than two
characteristics you will find out straight away categorical
variables with two characteristics are
also referred to as dicators
an example would be gender with the characteristics
male and female let's
say you coded female 0 and
male with 1 in which case female would be
die  reference category if
we now take a look at the recession
model and let's say the variable
x1 is gender then b1 is the
regression cent for gender how
can we now interpret 1
we said 0 is female and one
is male  So we simply put that
into the recession equation 1
for female 0 and for male 1
then we have 0 x p1 for a female person
and once per 1 for a male person
accordingly there is the
difference between male and
female on the slope is so  the
difference let's say we want to
predict the income of a person so y is the income
if a person is male
they earn b1 more than a
female person let's say the
recession model comes out that b12 is
100 then this would mean that
men  earn 200 euros on average more
than women
accordingly you want to predict the salary
of a person and this
person is male you get
the value 200 euros here a female
should get the value zero
euros we have now discussed how we use
variables with two values
now let's look at what we do
when we use a variable  e with more than two
characteristics let's say you want to predict
the consumption of a car based
on its hp
and the vehicle type and
let's say there are only three vehicle types
that sedans, sports cars and families
choose,
so the variable vehicle type has more
than two characteristics in this one  if there are three
characteristics in a recession model
, we can only consider categorical
variables with two characteristics,
so the question now is what do we do
so that we can use categorical variables with
more than two characteristics in a
repression model
, we have to create so-called dummy variables
, which means  that we
make three new variables from our variable with three characteristics,
each with two
characteristics,
so we have our vehicle
types here with the characteristics sedan, sports car
and family if we now
make a new variable from each characteristic, so
we have the variable is it
a sedan  it a spor  twagen and
is it a family if each of these three
variables has the values ​​0 and 1 or
no and yes is it a limousine yes
or no is it a sports car yes or
no or is it a family if yes or
no
accordingly before we had a
variable with  three
characteristics we now have three variables, each with two
characteristics what do we have to do when
preparing our data
you originally have a column with the
vehicle type where the individual vehicles
from a random sample are listed
the first vehicle is a sedan
the second sedan and the third
sports car  and so on and so forth
from this you now make three new
variables so you each have a
column for is sedan s sports car
and s family band what is the first car
the first car tore a sedan so
we write 0 for is sedan a 19
hp sports car  and in the case of families,
even a zero becomes
exactly the same as we do with the second
car, the third car  his sports car is
why we write at is limousines
and sports cars 1 and s family would
be new again so we have now formed our
dummy variables there is
one more thing to note
there will always be the number of characteristics
- 1 dani was
imaginary we know for example that
it is a limousine we can be
sure that it is not a family one
we know for example that it is a sports car
we can also be sure that
it is not a family one and if it is not a
limousine and it is not a sports car
then we are sure that it is  If a family
is accordingly, we
do not need this variable because this
information is superfluous,
so a minus 1 tami variable is always
formed, so it is sufficient
if we have the lady variable, is it a
sedan and is the sports car, of
course, you can
set them against each other, we could  just as well
leave out the muslims and add the family
and now i'll show you w  ie
you can easily go online with data tab
because the people of vaudois have witnesses
for just go to data tab de
click on the statistics calculator if
you want to use your own
data click on table teachers and
paste your data here i
just use the example data
we  want to calculate a regression
so we click on repression
i just want income as the dependent
variable and
age and the company as the independent variable
the company is a
variable with three characteristics bmw daimler
and vw
accordingly we have to form the variables here
this power  but datatec for you
alone if we now
scroll down to the results we see
that our model contains the age
bmw and daimler
so the dame variables
bmw and daimler were already formed the third
variant vw was left out and now
you can  interpret your tables as usual
or you look at yourself  e
summary in words
if i your independent variable
categorical but a dependent
variable then you have to calculate a logistic
recession for this
just watch my first video see you soon